Hank: Good morning John, I just got back home
to Missoula! Ooh, from tour. And I thought
it might be interesting to share with you
one full day in the life of the tour, what
it's like on the road. So here we go:
Step 1 - Wake up stupid early in the morning.
Step 2 - Put on your awesome new belt buckle.
Step 3 - Everything, no matter how disgusting,
goes in one bag.
Step 3 - Van Tetris.
Step 6 - Go exploring.
Step 9 - Breakfast.
Step 9.5 - Car breakfast. Keeps going.
Steps 10 through 800 is sit in the van. Andrew's
in there somewhere. What? Eyeball! [All singing]
She was looking kind of dumb with her finger
and her thumb in the shape of an L on her
forehead.
This is the part of the day where we try to
get Ethiopian food, but it's closed. And now
we're in a parking lot and it's a thousand
degrees Kelvin. And now I have to pee!
Step 3th - Arrive at the venue and comment
on how it's different from other venues you've
played at.
So they haven't been like this for the most
part. I mean, I don't want to tell you what
kind of bathrooms I've been spending time
in, but they're not like this one. You get
a riser today.
Rob: Yeah, I get to be really really high
up.
Hank: Nice.
[Rob plays guitar]
Hank: That was the part where Rob Scallon
plays me a personal concert. So I missed the
step where we load everything into the venue.
I feel bad about that. I don't know where
I was. I had to do something? I was on a phone
call.
Step 32 - Set up the merch stand.
Step 35 - Gimme my VIP bracelet!
Sam: These aren't just made out of paper,
these are made out of solid gold and platinum.
Hank: What are the sparkles made of?
Sam: Splatinum!
Hank: This is the green room, which is purple
here. You can tell this is a nice green room
because I have not seen a single piece of
pornographic graffiti.
Step 92 - Tune your guitar.
What are we doing now?!
Craig: INTERNET!
Joe: [Singing] 'Baby baby when you touch me
like this'
Hank: [Singing] -about what lies beneath these
clothes just by looking at me-
Step negative 8 - Dinner.
Step 801 - Meet friends.
Michael: Hi!
Step 4 - Make your set lists.
Step 5 - Paul takes off his shirt.
Step 25 - Pee. A bunch of different times
before we go onstage.
This is the part I hate the most is the waiting
to go onstage.
Driftless Pony Club just finished. I can tell
because of how wet Sam is.
Huddle up. Huddle up.
Joe: Alright, goop on three. Goop.
Part 83 - Do your hair in your camera before
you go onstage.
Part 84 - Go onstage.
I forgot the run of show. I don't go onstage
yet. [music and cheers]
Part 6,082 - Finish the show.
Ah! Oh, that's nice! Ah! Whoo!
Part 8 million - I'm going out to sign and
take pictures with people.
Step 94 - Get to the hotel, realize that you're
starving, and try and figure out a place to
eat.
Step 98 - Goof around.
Step 93 - Second dinners!
We just taught Andrew how to take off his
VIP wrist bracelet, during which process he
karate chopped his beer onto me.
Step 2 - Fall asleep in the van again.
Step firty toof - Go to bed and do it all
over again in the morning.
John, I'll see you on Tuesday.